I didn't get a chance to say thank you
for letting me and Zach do the show yeah
absolutely so I actually got you a
little something no way yeah man just a
little token of appreciation a little
gift yeah
yeah
okay
even though you're late
so I know how you love cocaine I mean
t-shirts okay uh so I got you a little
something
um so it says I'm in love with the Coco
get it because it says Cody dude I hate
this so much what do you mean I hate
this so much what are you talking so as
no it's just like I love Cody Co
there's no Coke reference in here they
but also if you look at the back there's
a giant eagle
anyways man
thanks dude thank you I really
appreciate it you're gonna wear that
right what you're gonna wear it not
right now but you know eventually for
sure I'm gonna wear this just like thank
you man I appreciate it you know I I
texted Noelle because I
like I saw a bunch of comments like the
the there's this joke now yeah has
extended past just like TMG Studios yeah
and it's like people will leave it like
a comment referencing this on some other
video and then someone will reply and be
like wait what is this in reference to
and someone that's in on the joke will
then reply and be like well he has this
crippling cocaine addiction and someone
will reply I've seen people be like oh
my God that's so horrible like I hope he
recovers well how else I texted him I
was like dude this joke is like it's
getting real like it's extending past
people that are in on the meme and it's
like people really think this is true
well how else does it explain you're
running marathons like [ __ ] 30 miles
40 miles it has to be yeah you think I'm
yeah yeah yeah yeah doing that but
you're not really you're not really
no right no are you sure yes
[Applause]
[Music]
I also am sweating yeah I know you are I
am sweating like holy [ __ ] by the way
another thing too
when you come into somebody's home right
or their spaceship in my culture you're
supposed to bring them
a little food you know what culture is
that um just Middle Eastern okay just
general Brown okay
got it Eddie Brown obviously
um so I cooked you a little something
you cooked me something yeah that you
really do have a full on stove back
there
what the [ __ ] dude are two copies of
green lights
Acres of plates for you
all right uh you've ever seen this
before no so basically you're so I've
never been to Brown or wherever
so basically
um there's like a cool trick you're
supposed to do where you get the rice
and you flip it oh yeah I have seen that
and it's open yeah so it's like kind of
scary yeah yeah do you want to try no
okay so I should I want you to do it
yeah okay I've noticed so am I
all right here goes nothing
dude I'm really excited it's okay you
got it relax relax I thought you like do
this
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go baby look at this did you
actually cook this yeah actually cook it
did you actually five hours dude forever
this took you five hours you gotta rinse
the rice and then I marinated the
chicken rinsing rice doesn't take five
hours so if you want it to be clean
right right boil it and then you gotta
cook it in this thing and you cook it
this morning I cooked it last night and
this morning and then you gotta layer it
uh I'm actually really excited dietary
restrictions right I'm just allergic to
chicken and rice
okay
it's a mess how is this and have you
cooked this before uh yes
and so I can just go in and oh and it's
kind of hot it is kind of hot yeah give
it a little lick
I mean I gotta say this is this really
is an incredible gift thank you yeah
it's just I thought this was a bit but
it's not even a joke it's like if you
full-on cooked me no I wouldn't a meal
for five hours there's a portable stove
sitting right there behind the chair
like this is a real deal I also drove
from Long Beach so I got up early at
like 5 a.m I started cooking man I feel
so bad that I was late
well now you learned your lesson it
feels so [ __ ] bad
oh yeah be careful you know what I I'm
actually not hungry because I'm on
cocaine
damn it wow it's really hot this [ __ ]
cooker back here is incredible
there you go
um
oh my God yeah
holy [ __ ]
wow let me know if you want me to cook
for your wedding or any house party I
gotta try them
I'm good I found let's go I'm a fan of
Brown
once you go Brown you know what they say
never go down yeah
what I don't know I don't know by the
way I mean I made I made
I made hella food so if anyone back
there wants to eat it and it's actually
incredibly good okay I'm glad the
chicken is like super tender and I like
that you did it like medium rare
no no no no it's got a nice pink Center
the chicken does I love chicken that is
what is cooked like this yeah I Like It
Raw right you know put it on the grill
for a minute yeah so I actually learned
how to make this uh at a Kebab
Restaurant I used to work at my dad's
Kebab Restaurant really and then it was
kind of [ __ ] because I'd worked there
with the cooks and I was like 15 16 and
if I did something wrong it would just
beat my ass
really yeah that's true yeah they just
slap me around they're like what the
[ __ ]
it was kind of fun that's why the food's
so good
I mean this chicken is actually
incredible okay I'm glad yeah I'm glad I
mean I did wake up
so this was at your dad's Kebab
Restaurant in in brown or wherever very
opposite of brown is that where you're
from Irvine yeah uh no I'm from New
Jersey Hackensack
oh are you yeah oh can I get a napkin
yeah of course no no thank you
thanks man you had that on Deck wow
dry ones too oh my God little there you
go
I'm I'm really listen I really
appreciate this sorry for the mess again